because your grandfather died in 78 at
the age of 73 with the
uh a horrific event that meant by the
way before even doing the interview with
you i've seen that video god knows how
many times in puerto rico when that
event took place
yes and he's doing a walk and and i
won't show the video but i'm sure the
viewers are going to see it i don't want
to show how you and i are talking
so he he dies in 78 when he's doing this
stunt walking across
two waterfront hotels i think it's like
a not a big distance that he went across
but he did it and he falls and
hits the car and uh uh dead on arrival
to the hospital
you're born a year later so you never
really had a chance to spend time with
him because i think you're a 79 baby and
he passed away in 78.
that's correct what what mindsets from
your grandfather
and your family was passed down to like
what stories have you heard about how he
was
at the dinner table what are the family
talking about they talked about he that
he was just an amazing man of
inspiration he was a very driven
individual a lot of his traits were
passed on to me
it's interesting there are 17 of us that
still walk the wire to this day
but i have a different drive than the
rest you've heard of nick wallenda
and and i would say the reason is is
because of that drive i've had the drive
to walk across the grand canyon
for instance i've had the drive to
continue to to push you know walking
across niagara falls took changing two
laws in two countries that were over 100
years old
that was just to get permission to do
the walk so that process
takes a lot of tenacity and and a lot of
grit
and uh that is something that he
certainly passed on to me
my parents say it's so interesting how
within a nine month span of his death i
was born
and there are so many similarities and i
never met him but i will tell you that
growing up i was always told of these
stories on
how he was always willing to push the
limits how he was always willing to step
out of his comfort zone how
he would he would return to the wire
1962 fatal accident two family members
killed one paralyzed in detroit michigan
my great grandfather not only was he
injured severely but he snuck out of the
hospital against the doctor's orders
just to get back on the wire the
following day
because he had that drive and there are
so many parallels
between his life and mine and by the way
crazy data is he was born i think
january 21st and you're born january
24th you guys are three days apart
that's correct i i know you're i know
you're a christian man you probably
don't even look at the data matching all
that other stuff but
for me my entire life i ask people about
birthdays and it's amazing how you guys
have a similar personality
and your birthday's three days apart so
you know
when i see the video i've seen it
multiple times
i have to tell you i i can't help myself
but my stomach
gets it gets uncomfortable we had
uh one of our guys just walked in here
before doing the interview
and he watched uh a couple of the videos
and he has vertigo and he
lost it right there he's like i can't
even watch this like you have to step
away
how often like when's the last time you
saw the video of you
your grandfather in puerto rico and when
people want to play it for you do you
look away
or are you comfortable seeing that one i
would tell you that that is a video that
i've seen
hundreds of times in fact i had a series
on the discovery channel
and it was really the science and
engineering behind what we do and in
that series i had the honor of
recreating that walk that he fell and
lost his life from and there
again many parallels in fact he was on
the sidewalk and was interviewed by a
reporter moments before he went up to
the wire
i was interviewed by that exact same
reporter on that same sidewalk moments
before i went up on the wire
so so many parallels but during that
series we did a bunch of research
and we had a bunch of geriatric
specialist doctors watch that video in
slow motion over and over again
and what we've always were told is that
the reality of why he lost his life was
because that wire was rigged in properly
and
and we know that for sure in fact the
way it was stabilized was improper
rather than that wire being
rock solid which what he was was what he
was accustomed to
it actually moved quite a bit because of
those stabilizer ropes that were coming
off of it
and uh he was trained and prepared for
any stable wire but the reality was at
73 years old
your heart isn't prepared to take the
amount of adrenaline in the adrenaline
rush that he would have gotten
from an unstable wire and they say that
he didn't notice that it was unstable
in fact in fact my father was supposed
to be there to rig it as well as my
uncle and they both had previous
engagements
actually my dad had to stay home because
my mom had just had a miscarriage and he
was there with her
so he had a couple other guys on his
crew set it up and they they took a
couple shortcuts
and in the end what that did was it
caused his adrenaline to go up to the
point where
we believe he went into cardiac arrest
went down to the wire
which is what we're all trained to do
and we'll talk about the accident in
2017 where i did just that
he went down to the wire to hold on and
at that point in cardiac arrest
he couldn't hold on and that's in the
end what caused him to lose his life it
wasn't the wind
it wasn't a lack of balance it was
actually we believe
it was an unstable wire and then of
course the fact that he couldn't
take that amount of blood pressure into
his heart